hello everyone
this is the Bulgin today I thought I
would do something a little bit
different than one I usually do you my
youtube channel I'm not as just play a
game as myself not gonna be doing a
house in scp-049 or any not still I
figured before I start to play this game
I should preface it with a disclaimer
okay even though even the way of voice
acted numerous characters in this game I
have never really played it properly
before I have like access the console
and like noclip through the mop to see
the different NCP's that I've voiced but
I've never actually tried to play it
before so I'm gonna try and do it today
I'm gonna try but I I feel I feel like I
have to preface it with the disclaimer
because people looking at it will are
looking at me playing this will just
cringe at hi little I know him so yeah I
just did oh I'm starting off on like
medium
I assume ukuleles medium so I'm gonna
start off on now and see how it goes
this could end up being a very short
episode I'm probably not gonna stop if I
die because she's it would take way too
long that actually
I don't know okay okay I'm familiar with
this part like everybody is okay right
on behalf of the SCP foundation and our
staff we welcome you to an exciting one
month working period in our top-secret
research facilities unfortunately the
exact details of your upcoming work
assignments are highly classified but
please read this document carefully to
make your stay as safe and as pleasant
as rude okay brand Daniel whatever good
see not everybody can have a sexy voice
like you most of us have to put it on
well speaking of sexy voices they're
just mirror they updated the models of
the soldiers as well pretty cool so
they've added more chech out to the
intro - oh cool you can see other
declines here - do you meet these guys
wow there's a lot of noise going on
I got voice that guy - thank you
sup my dudes okay
there we go okay
saving is only permitted on clickable
monitors okay well that's different okay
Hey yeah okay it's locked
what about here that was he this was
always the door you went through right
hey I hear them everywhere being locked
no this has to be open she thought I'd
be scared of my own voice
okay
that sign is all on us in the background
caution the authorized personnel oh it's
not a keycard job what what what was
that I don't even know what that is what
what oh this is why I'm not doing a
fierce counting right about a 30 year
old mind loving like a masochist Oh hmm
I'm guessing that's I can't go through
though to see the lot I take it okay
achievement unlocked the architect I
wish I knew I'm really embarrassed I
don't know what I see B this is a B
containment zone SCP it
a keycard neither teddy bears gone oh
boy and over my depth there I really
should have a playthrough before oh wait
okay well there you go that's my first
attempt yeah let's do it let's skip the
intro sequence this time because there's
no point in going over and over again oh
I can hear the coments already you've
talked dude do some research next time
try not to swear probably have ludes I'm
not I'm not a very PG person but because
of the odd pocalypse stuff at the minute
it makes it kind of hard okay so out of
here
under the right offer sake what am I
supposed to do well I'm well I'm dead
again oh my god dammit let's go again
keep on entering my name scp-172 who you
glasses
and I don't know if I'm either there's
gonna be another episode of this nobody
is gonna want to watch this surely good
Lord like okay let's go again man okay
so offended so it's always gonna be
there
hi am I gonna get out of here is this
open died or something I am so so
confused right now I have to blink okay
so he just disappears then okay
the last time you put continue I will
generate an access memory though I guess
not
I see p12
Oh No key card okay what's this 11:23 no
we can get in here mm-hmm object class
see if that should be okay right there
Oh Cosmo
Kico
okay it's a bridge or see little end
over in these tunnels
not ever it's out okay great I'm gonna
keep hard oh there's another one
this is on right sides like it's on okay
see the Teddy's not here this time that
was a thing that just happened
all these random noises and SCP
containment breaches stopped work well
I'll not note everyone I'm gonna end
this here now that you all know how
ridiculously bad I am at this game if
you want me to play it more I will but
if you don't
I completely understand completely
this has been the volgen and maybe I'll
see you later bye
you